[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is completely ridiculous and I
can't believe I'm actually in a position
to get away with [ __ ] like this but it
actually works I think is pretty funny
check it out
[Music]
maybe
part folding
run naked sorry baby I was just trying
to show great job bringing coffee he has
a fun fact on how I take my coffee
the cut way I can down it in one go and
get the kick for the day
this video sponsored by story blocks who
I work with all year round story blocks
is an unlimited stock video audio and
imagery platform I promised I'd be as up
france as possible about which videos
are sponsored so this is me doing that I
find story blocks to be a hugely useful
creator tool and where they sponsor me
is by enabling me to make rad content
the creative license is totally mine is
no red tape so if you enjoy my videos
head over the story blocks to up your
creative game tell your stories better
and to support them because they support
me
[Music]
the hindsight this puppy wasn't a great
idea and I'll tell you why not
gabs and i temporarily moved to this
house on the beach it's quite literally
on the sand but I can't surf due to
lockdown and being so close to perfect
and ridden waves and not being able to
surf them is enough to drive one
completely mad
since I'm not allowed surfing to induct
on I'm gonna take my childhood friend
Kenny this Lego surfer tow surfing
behind my drone and he has a foreshadow
of me doubting this idea
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
what do you know I crashed yet another
drone but adamant sin not pollute the
ocean and to retrieve Kenny and my drone
we wait until 6 a.m. the next day which
is the legal time to walk outside your
house join lockdown in South Africa and
headed to the craft
[Music]
oh my god what did that
yes
although back the city
I'll serve is not on there
however this was the best possible way
for him to go doing what he loved most
so he threw him the memorial he would
have wanted
r.i.p little brood and then I got to
uncovering the surfing footage I can
hopefully salvage from the drone Benny
love this editing room because scabs can
fall asleep right there on that day
Bidwell
I continued to work I don't know just I
just dig having somebody there while I
work I generally only start working
we're gonna get super late
it really enjoyed the quiet yeah but
what is this what are we what what is
this what are we doing this is a this is
like a vlog I guess that I'm gonna be
making videos like this more often you
know in between my other videos every
month just something raw something more
behind-the-scenes something to track my
ideas fails successes and be able to
share it with you so yeah I'm apt I'm
amped on this I think this is a good
idea sing for us this is a good good
relationship starter
[Music]
[Music]
if they started dairy again Joey is
absent my sausage dog wasn't allowed to
come here because of hate restrictions
which is tough for us because we love
him like his son like a like a real
human sir I even tattooed he's faced a
really bad image a hand poke tattoo of
his face on my leg
Oh
[Music]
that's actually a pretty interesting
idea to tell the stories behind my
tattoos you know
weird yeah they are actually pretty
weird but I'm going to tell the story of
each of them I'm going to start at the
very first tattoo if I told you the
story about my lips basically I have
this kiss mark tattooed on my bum cheek
and the story goes like this
I was 18 years old and after working in
the film industry as a runner I saved up
enough money to go to Bali for my gap
year this was three Instagram days I was
with four friends and we traveled to
Islands East to some powered surf this
wave we always wanted to call lady peach
on return when I was driving I got
caught in a drug scam I've made a video
about this entire experience if you're
interested I'll link it below and yeah I
go into extreme detail in this video but
long story short the police planted
drugs on us after I crashed the car and
spent days in an interrogation room in a
prison here they tried to extort as much
money out of me as possible they also
made a lot of violent threats so on the
day of a parade I saw the gates to the
prison were opened so were able to fled
where we hid away from the authorities
for three days until the South African
embassy came to our rescue
they then flew us back to body for one
night we had to leave the car and
language behind and I guess in the
ecstasy
being a prison break 18 year old on the
Moose and body and after many Benton's
were involved I thought I'd get a symbol
to say kiss my ass corruption there for
the lips seemed like a good idea as well
as this hairstyle like I mentioned to
gab sighs I have no idea whose ellipses
are they could even be from the man in
this photograph that was a joke
and like I was talking about earlier how
story blocks really helps you telling
your stories better in a case like that
where I didn't have great video footage
of that trip I utilized a lot of stocks
from the story block sites in order to
to help get across fragments from my
memory and pass them over to you in a
visual way if you go over to the story
block site you'll see how many great
stocks they have for video for photos
and it just you know it really helps
better your video again so go over to
the link that I've put below and check
them out
not just about sums up this vlog and
I'll do the sign out when I'm doing my
sick of everything in the world
crying crying is basically barbecuing
bits yeah it's it's barbecuing but it
was started here in South Africa and
it's called Brian
I hope you enjoyed this more blog style
video if you thought it was [ __ ] let me
know this is a two-way communication but
I hope you enjoyed it other than that
don't forget your awesome beer and I'll
see you soon
[Music]
you